well I suppose that depends what you
mean by development and I'm reminded of
Gandhi's response when he was asked what
he thought about Western civilization
and he said it would be a good idea I
think development human development
would be a good idea what we mostly call
development is not actually development
it's a piracy it's just grabbing stuff
no grabbing stuff and protecting the
environment are not compatible we can't
have an economy in which those who get
their first and take everything off the
table or rewarded that's not compatible
with what we need to do to survive
sustained winds 21st century so we need
a new definition of development but if
development means learning how to grow a
hundred plants and feed a family of a
smaller garden yeah that's definitely
compatible if it's the development that
comes from knowledge and wisdom as
opposed to the development that comes
from grabbing and appropriating it's not
only compatible it's essential